going to be a weird question
but at which points in your lives did
you realize your parents were human
beings
uh what do you
mean okay I was going to throw it out to
see if anyone get got the vibe a very
openend question I know what you're
saying cuz you you see your parents as
like infallible growing up I I remember
I remember I thought like they were
superh humans and then yeah you feel
like they they they know everything they
brought you into this world they can
they they they take you out of this they
figure they provide they do everything
so like to you they're like they are
like Gods almost right because they are
like they control everything you do yeah
uh and then you get to like 18 and then
if your parents says something that
isn't right and then you can just Google
it and you find out it's wrong and
you're like huh for me it was probably
when I realized that although my parents
really heavily pressured me to go to
university mhm they didn't go to
university themselves that was probably
the where I'm just like oh is that why
you guys want me to go because like you
guys didn't or you know and that's the
moment when I realized I was like oh I'm
doing something that my parents couldn't
even do and that made me realize like oh
[__] like my parents aren't perfect you
know they look perfect they act perfect
around me but they're just like everyone
else yeah so that's probably the moment
for me what about you that's wait why
why did them not go to university make
you realize that because I thought they
were just like perfect like the the way
they because the way the way they LED
their life was just like you know all
the right things happened they you know
they got to like all the necessary stops
and but that also hum that that also
like humbled me at the same time being
like Oh I can be just as happy as my
parents without necessarily going down
that route and that kind of made me look
at them as humans in kind of a Different
Light yeah you know I I think there was
a moment where like I kind of like
drifted away from my parents for like
like during like the univers happens
your that generally happens in your like
late teens yeah like late teens early
adulthood you want to find yourself yeah
yeah you're trying to I'm trying to find
you know I was trying to find myself and
I remember having this conversation with
my mom like like a bit after that period
where you know me and my mom like I I I
used to be like the biggest [__]
mama's boy of all time of course I was
and then afterwards I kind of like did
the 180 and I'm just like actually I'm
an individual I don't need to talk to my
mom at all my mom I've left that part of
my life behind me I remember having this
conversation and then I remember having
a conversation with my mom and then she
just started talking about some of her
like insecurities and I just remember
like thinking oh w h that's a that's a
that's a human
trait that's not that's not a mom trait
you're this you're this Beacon of
Happiness what you talking about
insecurities my mom's always happy she's
always behind the motherboard there is a
beating heart I just I just it just like
hit me like a ton of bricks like oh my
mom is a human being with insecurities
like me me and she's feelings yeah and
then and then that was like that that
started a path to me kind of like
getting real close to my mom and my
parents again and I'm like real happy
that like me realizing my parents were
just like human beings who were very
much invaluable and had insecurities
like me I was like oh I get along with
them way better than I ever did as a kid
because it's like totally different now
but some some people you know some
parents go through their entire lives
never opening up that side of themselves
to their children and so like I think
you were put in a very rare position
where I don't know if it's rare would
you say it's more common than not I
think your parents to eventually do that
with their kids I mean it really depends
I think I don't think it happens as
often as it should yeah um I don't think
it's as widespread um as it should beely
because it's there's there's and it's
always a fine balance between seeing
your parent as like a parent you know
seeing them as just another like
yourself who maybe one day we're going
to be parents as well and our kids are
going to look at us the same ways and
I'm I'm just wondering you know was
there ever a point uh I I I should
probably ask this to my own parents was
there ever a point where you were like
scared I would I would as a kid sus out
the facade you know be like wait a
minute my parents are just people they
aren't super humans they aren't Gods
it's just you know you just load up that
real life game of Among
Us like someone's someone's not right
here some's someone's a little SAU right
now I think maybe when you're a parent
you just have to play that role for so
long of being like this figure that is
so reliable sometimes you just think
that like you've been doing it for so
long that you have to be that right like
you have to you can't be this person as
emotions as she has yeah but uh I think
you know obviously I think a lot of kids
appreciate it especially when they're
older that you can talk to them about
yeah more personal things go once this
so goes live I'm just going to expect
dad my dad's going to kill me let's
let's okay let's let Emil to Joey son I
did not hit you as a I did not beat you
as a child I dominated you remember it I
won't go away all right let's let's
start some beef right now with our
parents all right what no I'm scared no
no no no no this this this is the real
this is the real question this you want
me on death row okay this is the real
question we're in this together guys all
right here's the question okay do you
think you're more like your dad dad or
your mom oh I'm 100% more like my mom
you're more like your mom yeah 100% how
so I'm just way more like her I'm just
I'm more chatty I share a lot of traits
with her I don't look like my dad I love
my mom maybe I'm maybe I look like the
mail cuz I think I think I'm more like
my dad I think you're more like your dad
as do you know okay are you the same way
Joey because I feel like when we were
kids we might have been more like our
moms or at least I I was like way more
like my mom and my mom was like yo he's
going to grow up and be just like me
dude I looked like my mom when I was
little I I think I actually have a photo
of like me when I was a can you go get
my phone but like I I don't know if this
is just like a Hau thing but like boys
who are born Hau like they grow up
looking Japanese as [__] and then one
day the Western jeans are just like let
me stop that for a
second let me see let me show cuz like H
I think I have it on my phone anyway
keep talking while I find this yeah like
I like as a kid I I always felt like I
was going to grow up to be like my mom
and then As I Grew Older I don't know
when it happened it was just such a
subtle thing but then I just started
turning more and more into my dad and I
had this moment
where it was it was like a month ago or
something where I was just like uh it it
was in when we were in England and
Sydney was like you walk like your dad
and I was like what you mean I walk like
my dad and she's like I don't know just
your posture just that's when you know
it's game
over and and that's how that's when you
realize oh it's game over I've
officially transformed perfectly into my
dad now okay this is me when I was three
oh my God that's you do look way more
like your mom in that photo I look
Japanese as [__] right yeah what the
heck this is the same person B cut yeah
that's cuz I hated haircuts oh F yeah
but like yeah no totally like I think
the moment when you start to I think we
talked about this in a previous epode
but like the moment when you start to
just without even thinking imitate the
exact same things you've seen your dad
do do you make the same sounds as your
dad oh 100%
like I'm trying to stop that whenever I
do anything that my parents do I'm like
I and I know I did it I'm like I got to
stop that dude the like dude the other
day when when we were having the
Halloween uh party at our house I I
physically stopped myself from saying oh
[__] I'm shitfaced like I I had to
physically stop myself from doing that
cuz I'm like that's something my dad
would do very Charming when your dad
would do that yeah it is it's Charming
when my dad does it it's not Charming
when I do
it was funny so you reached the point
where you're like [__] I'm doing the
things my parents do uh I should stop
that and then I've come I've come to the
point where I'm like but it's just so
natural it just I'm I'm fighting against
my bloodline here I just I just need to
do it that is true I'm going to get to
that point probably in like my late 30s
where I'm just like you know what I'm I
probably won't even be drinking alcohol
and I'll be like oh [__] [__]
face just tired waiting for that right
moment to bring that out exactly yeah so
but like I say now I'm definitely more
like my dad um you're more like your dad
I'm more like my dad so you're the only
one that's more like your mom I guess so
I wonder
why what about your brothers like are
they more like one of the parents more
like my dad all of them yeah I think so
yeah my older brother he's kind of half
half off I say he has very discernable
traits from both right right but I think
this my job's yapping my job's talking
so not my mom was the much more
talkative one so I think I you know I I
my mom's always very eager to talk and
my dad will be like he my my dad talks
too but my my dad's my dad he'll just be
like how you doing my dad
talks talk my my dad but my dad's from
the generation as well where he just can
like fix anything and build anything
right cuz right now he's just remodeling
the whole house and he knows how to do
most of the stuff by himself and I'm
like
how do you how do you know this what
what skill tree did this how did you
Speck into this yeah like I I feel like
I'm such a useless man he's in the build
for sure yeah like I've got my drill
bits I'm just like what do I what can I
use them on huh oh nothing nothing
nothing in Japan okay it's being bred
out of us guys wake up they're trying to
they're trying to get it out of us man
they're not letting us use our tools
it's not DIY anymore man I want to DIY
so bad I just want I just want to make a
shitty is that how you know we're
getting old I just want to it's a skill
I want to get better at like I feel like
it's like a RuneScape class that I've
been putting off for too long and I know
right there do I I recently found this
like YouTube channel of this Japanese
guy who uh creates like real life clay
sculptures of Pokémon sick but like
really [__] like amazing quality and he
like films all of his like uh you know
uh process in doing it and the entire
time I'm just like [__] I wish I could
do that I wanty to build a table I just
see how it feels I want to I want to
build something without an instruction
manual you know just ik Ikea doesn't
count Amazon doesn't count I just want
to build something with the raw
materials and go all right let's see
what that just sounds like a [__]
video idea I think I think it's cuz half
half the the population uh that was that
was destined to be amazing Builders have
now become coffee experts on Tik
Tok how did that Trend
start you see all the comments are like
if if cofy enthusiasts spent 1% of their
brain power on on Advent in humanity
we'd be flying by now we' be I think we
actually have killed cancer if got the
Enthusiast have like had spec into the
medical field they'll create mini black
holes to make to make the perfect
espresso
pool so just activate your Gravitron
Cannon to allow the espresso to pour
evenly through the titanium
filter it is [__] how how in intricate
these these espresso things are it's so
[__] damn yeah I I saw the one of like
the evolution of the different kind of
like Contraptions that they bu the one
with the [__] they like the thing the
like thing that they used to like spread
out the coffee spread out the it's like
a Rolex mechanism just to like spread it
out perfectly oh like the little ones
with the little hairs on it the hairs
that just started out as like a little
like pine cone that that was like 3D
printed and then companies made like
advancements of that and they got to the
point where they like had multiple gears
just turning around so you get the
spread I love how the the the a lot of
the comments are always like that one
coffee friend who says that making
coffee at home is
cheaper that's me I'm becoming that
friend I just like my machine I just
like grinding it I don't like all this
[__] with the moment we got to like
temp it down we got to start like
[__] fluffing it around putting in
like another filter I'm like this is too
much [__] to clean yeah I like my thing
cuz it's like a Lego thing I I make the
coffee it's like John Wick loading is
gone except I'm loading up the the milk
fro it's like parts and they all
dishwash and when I'm done my coffee I
just take them in the dishwasher and I'm
like this is easy this is great I do the
grind and the tamping down but like I
don't go anything beyond grinding is
great like actually like the the one
thing I I say that changed my coffee
game and made coffee taste so much
better is just grinding beans yeah it's
so easy to do and it makes coffee taste
so much better and fun great way to wake
up in the morning too dude the smell
yeah uh but I I'm not going down this
maybe I will maybe if have a long see
going 5 years from now like when when
you stop the YouTube you grind and
you're like [__] I have half an hour in
the morning or an hour or however long
it takes to make some of these coffees
cuz I swear I watch some of these Tik
toks uh he stops the YouTube grind he's
going to start the coffee grind I no no
no no I got to I got to do something El
some of these coffee makers could go on
to like the end of one piece by the time
they finish make my espresso man like I
don't know how many steps they put into
that but it is insane uh but they seem
happy hey if they're satisfied there are
two types of coffee drinkers people who
just want the caffeine intake and
people some people who want to discover
a new dimension of coffee making